david david david wants to know why he
keeps getting ghosted and have women
text him first all right david
hey how you doing rich good good to see
you so yeah you can hear me
yes yes
uh so pretty much um i'll text like uh
girls like from school that i i used to
go with and uh
you know uh even some people like i even
talked to and there's nothing wrong with
like going up to them talking them uh
just casual conversations but whenever i
text them on you know social media i get
to know them a little bit and like to
invite them like hey let's go out to eat
they're like oh sure
and then that's it like they don't they
don't text me back
feed them they want you to put food in
their belly they don't want you for
anything else
yeah like well they said oh i'll get
back with you and
nothing why why do you think that
they're ghosting you dave
i think
they say that just to like okay
um
i don't think i'm their type but i think
they're just saying that to be nice i
think that's what it is
you know what i mean so why do you think
that they're not that you're not their
type
i don't know maybe
like i guess how i am or maybe just how
i look maybe the looks
like i really like your look hang on
we're gonna go down this rabbit hole so
what's wrong with your look
i mean
i just have uh i mean i'm not like too
bad right now like i'm losing a lot of
weight you know i've been working out
every day i've been reading your book
uh hotel following
i'm 5 8 the last i weighed myself i was
185. okay so you're skinny fat
yeah exactly you have a belly
a little bit belly it's getting flat you
have [ __ ] tits
uh
a little bit i mean it's like going down
a lot so so and i can see that there's
like you know fat in your cheeks in your
face right yeah yeah like you see a
little bit double chin you know how old
are you
uh 23
23
yes okay um i would i would get blood
labs run to find out
if your endocrine system is running
properly if you've got high estrogen and
low testosterone which i would which i
would be guessing is is probably what's
contributing to your physique right now
you can fix that with diet and exercise
and you know good sleep and
supplementation
there are products here in my supplement
store where do you live in the states
uh yeah in the united states okay so the
so the fulfillment center will ship to
you so get the testosterone booster and
get the estrogen metabolizer
and start taking that along with a good
proper exercise routine and diet make
sure you eat good food right and get rid
of the [ __ ] tits get rid of the belly
you know get rid of the fat on your face
um
like that's that's a big part of it for
for just about everybody you know start
because everybody's like i don't
understand why the women don't like me
and that goes to me it's like okay first
of all do you look like the kind of dude
that she's going to want to throw
herself at
right because i mean that's really what
you want right like you want her like
what did your private thing say over
here it said something like how to get
women to message you
yeah exactly right and have women text
you first if you want women to slide
into your dms or if you want women to be
like hey dave i haven't seen you in a
while
let's go get that dinner
right just you know straight out of the
blue
right hey wyd right you want to exactly
yes yes exactly yeah you you have to
look like the guy that other women want
to be with and other men want to be
right right
it's really not that complicated
right yeah what is it just recently i
was watching one of your videos like
you're talking about estrogen
and uh like i've been doing a whole
clean out like i remember i was like
drinking some milk like i thought it was
good for me like chocolate milk turns
out what you're saying soy milk it had
soy in it i was like [ __ ] that you know
i'm sorry that's okay but forget that
yeah i was like forget that i completely
got rid of it and i saw like some
difference you know what i mean in my
voice a little bit and you know how you
said the [ __ ] just went down a little
bit so look it's gonna take like six to
twelve months to do like a full
transformation from like where you are
today to like what what will look a lot
more attractive
so it's going to take time right so you
just have to put yourself into it um
moth made a good point here in the
comments is women don't text you first
literally unless you're in the top one
percent right right so like top one
percent kind of guys
have maxed out in every area that they
possibly can
right they got their looks sorted they
got their money sorted they got game
they know how to deal with women they've
got frame they're interesting they're
captivating all that good stuff right
um what's up with the moon poster on the
wall like what do you like to do for
hobbies are you an astronomer do you
have a telescope like what do you do
no i mean i like space and all that but
really that's just like for a podcast
thing that we have uh live with uh my
roommate so okay that's just like a
background thing you know okay so i mean
like
what do you do that's interesting that
you can invite a woman into that's gonna
be captivating for it for her well i
mean usually i've been doing like
photography and trying to get into like
film making like video editing and stuff
like that
video editing
okay so if you put anything together
that's interesting that you know i mean
funny or
yeah i've been trying to do like more
funny vlogs like you know those
youtubers how they have like million
subscribers trying to get like that
style going on you know what i mean just
trying to experiment see like where i'm
at and then what i like at least you're
doing something right i mean like i like
hearing that it's just you haven't found
something that's got your traction i
mean you don't have the you don't have
like the fast growing channel you don't
have a social um like i could tell you
right now like you could look exactly
like you look right now but put out
really interesting funny like video
content or like tick tocks or shorts or
something like that and have like a
million followers and you'd have women
sliding into you like they'd be like oh
my god i left that last post that i had
like you know like it would happen so
you know social proof helps but it's not
the end-all be-all of things right like
that like there's some weird looking
dorks on on on tiktok and instagram and
i've seen them with gorgeous you know
women and they put out really really
funny content it's captivating it you
know it gets shared a lot and that
social proof helps but that's not all of
it it's like you know you want women to
to come at you first you know is what
your ass was in the private dms there
you got to look the part right i mean
scale of one to ten zero being the worst
ten being the absolute best version of
yourself where are you right now
i just told myself this yesterday i was
like a six point two out of ten okay and
you've read my book right
yes so
so so what do i say about you know if
you're not like a seven or higher
oh then you need to just focus on
yourself don't worry don't even bother
so like why are you asking me why women
aren't messaging you right right you
already have the answer
you just want me to tell you it
exactly yeah it was to confirm even
though i read it yeah okay so just so
just work on all that stuff and reinvest
your time on that and you'll find like
you know six to 12 months you're going
to be looking and feeling a lot better
right okay sounds good
don't don't waste your time like asking
women out for dinner right now because
all they're going to do is they're going
to use you for a free meal
exactly honestly like you know fix your
diet fix your exercise routine i would
get blood labs pulled to see what's you
know what's going on see if there's any
deficiencies anywhere you might be
deficient in some vitamins like vitamin
d stuff like that vitamin d for sure so
once a year like it shouldn't cost you
that much um i think in all of my videos
towards the bottom there's uh a link for
let's get check still which is a home
testosterone test kit i think for like
200 bucks you can get like the full
panel that checks everything it's it's
pretty accurate you want like full
accurate with a full panel just go to
your doctor and have the mortar laps for
everything just say look you know i'm
not feeling good i'm lethargic
you know i got a lot of belly fat you
know i've been putting on
you know been working out it's just not
losing it so like i want to you know
find out what's going on right um
and start with that and then you know
start start working on those things and
fix them you just eliminate one thing
after the other okay i got some extra
fat on my face i got [ __ ] tits i got
you know pear-shaped body okay let's
work out let's eat properly uh i'm not
interesting you know my spare time what
can i do to invite a woman into my life
that's gonna be interesting right you
know she's gonna want to like message me
and be like hey dave
right you want her to come at you you
got to be an interesting guy
exactly yeah all right
make sense yes sir everybody thank you
so much appreciate good luck take care
you